bindi Irwin gushes over the first time  she saw boyfriend chandler Powell in  khakis the 18 year old Dancing with the  Stars champ and her 19 year old  boyfriend sat down with et's Cameron  Mathison at the Australia Zoo where she  couldn't stop smiling over her man's  attire I love senior hockey now makes me  so happy  it's kind of weird though because I see  you through the zoo now first time you  walked out wearing khakis  oh it was phenomenal I didn't really  know how to feel about it it was it was  really real but it was like it was kind  of one of those moments that was a real  defining moment for me because it's only  the people who are the closest to us  that get that cocky so it was kind of  like there's this really big stout Oh  for more with bindi and Chandler and  their secret to handling love in the  spotlight  tune in to ET Monday night